I'm gonna start by saying this I really
enjoyed what I saw of this show I think
it's gonna be a big hit so congrats on
that thank you I want to start with a
what year do you think this show takes
place in its timeless how it starts and
it says this year because then in any
are you watching it's that year yeah but
I love it I think there is also
something about filmic ly that we've
sort of we still hold the sort of
sixties onra and fifties junior and high
esteem and I and and everything that we
especially in America it seems to hold
near and dear are those iconic fifties
visuals and so there's there's the
definitely we're drawing on that if you
I need to ask Lisa super or Angus jothee
about that but but it feels that that
we're not stuck in time but rather that
it's a sort of other worldliness that
sits comfortably in that in that
subversion of that era that really has a
16 elements is it stoke some of this
brain stuff off because I think it's a
little one of BS is that bs there that's
one of the things also that I like about
the show is that it just jumps right in
it doesn't try to catch you up it just
inserted yeah and this was like what
where she's at what she's dealing with
yeah and you just catch up to that yeah
that job don't part we're not
patronizing the audience just like be
with us join us get on board immediately
if not we'll see you later there's
another train coming a lot of shows
nowadays kind of like well I feel that
with this on-demand as amazing as it is
that they kind of spoon-feed the
audience sometimes because they're
trying to build as well so quickly and
this drops you right into it and yeah
yeah let's the audience be immersed from
the get-go rather than just telling you
this happens here this happens they're
looking blue what do you think would
surprise people to learn about the
making of Sabrina if anything it usually
surprises people to know that the first
two episodes took a month each
Weight Watchers which was pretty it was
pretty let's rewind that for one second
the first two episodes yeah they took a
month about a month each there were
movies yeah they were there were little
films Wow and also everyone came
together as was like trying to figure
out you know everyone's language
together and then after that very just
complicated because they had all these
amazing energies that that would be us
and I guess / chemistry and finding
where our strengths and weaknesses were
and how they could unite us to to to
produce the most powerful product and
that meant doing it in lots of different
tones and lots of different readings and
filming all of that so then Roberto
could set with his opera and and
construct what you see on the screen oh
so basically so some of the scenes so
basically you're saying like some of
those scenes played Oh a few different
ways yeah found it in the Edit yeah and
then so what happened after you film the
second episode there was like a little
bit of a break no they knew they right
that we were finding we were really
exploring torn and by the time we
finished doing the second movie /
episode and there were really clear as
to you know who who we were where we sat
in the grander picture and what our
connections were and so is that all down
to tone and that's why it's so Americas
we spent that time and we made it so
good yeah and then and then right when
it starts to chop you right in you know
by then we all had like our shorthand so
you're kind of like we just want all I
see me me and I say what you mean you
know who you are
yeah so you can start making like
choices more naturally without having to
think about it you just know who you are
after how much did you know after the
second episode of the rest of the arc of
the season and how much were you finding
it out script by script what Roberto
um likes to give nuggets here in there
lady he doesn't want to give too much
away cuz he wants to keep you know that
everyone guessing as well because there
are some times that if he has an idea
cuz you know he's his head like it it
seems to explode with them great ideas
and so if you have an idea or put it in
and then if his other idea Trump's this
idea
want to change him and make it even
better 'yes it works out that way so
sometimes he doesn't want it to say too
much so that you don't get stuck on a
certain idea yourself so you have it we
have a we have a vague idea of who we
are
yeah we're going yeah so we get the A to
B or rather we get the A to Z and he
does all the rest of the alphabet fills
it in beautifully with a incredibly
unusual and construction of language we
know some of the what's we just don't
know the house and then why the
intricacies and then they really color
it um
I've spoken to a lot of actors and each
person likes to work a different way
some people love music before they're
about to film some people love silence
like everyone has their methodologies I
like cheese before I film is this is
it's a writer in the contract yes smooth
blue cheese right Bert for each of you
though um how do you typically like to
get ready when you're getting ready to
film do you have like a certain rhythm I
have this eccentric miss that I'll
listen to you to get myself in Ambrose
mode mine is constantly fluctuating I
really like to watch the actors that I'm
working with and learn from them and
just try to try to constantly learn and
try to try to make it better all the
time so sometimes that could mean you
know listening to to good music that I'm
into at the time or that could mean
watching the scene that's filming prior
to my scene and and pick me up a little
nuggets here and there
you know geez geez my life is my last
thing for you memorable moments from
filming is there for each of you is
there a day or two that you will always
remember from filming the show oh there
are me actually they're actually racking
up I know what this sure does I think
beautifully with in terms of its
production value is that it's it gives a
very respectful nod to some of the most
iconic moments that have happened in the
horror genre and so there's moments that
you're in and you're kind of weak
vaguely recreating in
in the composition of that shot and then
you find yourself in that shot that that
had an impact on you when you were
growing up because it might have been in
the Exorcist or Rosemary's Baby or just
something that's sort of very respectful
and not to what's gone before us because
nothing is as you know nice as
Shakespeare and that's all been said
before we're just saying it better
you